supongamos que yo soy un fondo de
pensiones y tengo dinero para prestar
claro yo quiero prestar ese dinero
porque quiero que sea productivo mi
dinero no simplemente quiero que se
quede ahí quiero obtener intereses ahora
cabe mencionar que me conviene más
prestarle a personas que no sean
gobierno me conviene más prestarle
personas porque de esta manera yo
obtengo mejores intereses así que me voy
a dibujar esta soy yo yo soy el fondo de
pensiones fondo de pensiones ahora
supongamos que existe una corporación
una corporación por acá llamemos ley en
general mujer se hacen vehículos y
porque he escuchado sobre ellos le vamos
a llamar la corporación a corporación
y ellos quieren dinero prestado aquí
estoy yo yo les quiero prestar dinero
tal vez lo necesiten para am para hacer
una fábrica o qué sé yo sin embargo yo
les quiero prestar dinero pero hay un
pequeño problema el problema es que yo
soy un fondo de pensiones quizás
supongamos que soy el fondo de pensiones
para maestros jubilados o mecánicos
jubilados y entonces yo yo en mi carta
ni contrato dice que yo solo puedo
invertir en cosas seguras
no puedo andar por ahí jugando con el
dinero de las personas yo debe cuidar su
dinero porque estamos hablando de
jubilados entonces yo no puedo andar ahí
venturosa prestando dinero por todas
partes digamos sólo se me permite
invertir en cosas calificadas triple-a
bueno lo mejor doble a porque las cosas
triple as son es algo con muchísima
seguridad con muy poca probabilidad de
fallo entonces vamos a invertir en cosas
doble a se me permite sólo invertir en
cosas doble a ahora supongamos que la
corporación nada tiene una una
calificación digamos w de hecho es una
buena es un momento para pensar quién
hace estas calificaciones tal vez tú
digas o seguramente vas a el gobierno
porque el gobierno es lo suficientemente
objetivo como para calificar a estas
compañías de una manera objetiva sin
embargo qué crees no son ellos de hecho
son compañías privadas las que las que
califican entonces de hecho esto lo vi
en un vídeo sobre obligación de deudas y
bueno llega a nuestro escenario una
agencia de calificación crediticia
tenemos aquí a moody a moody es la
agencia de calificación crediticia que
calificó a la corporación
con w ellos dicen bueno corporación a tú
eres bastante bueno
sin embargo eres bastante sensible a la
economía puedes fallar en cualquier
momento así que te vamos a poner una w
y yo como fondo de pensiones digo wow a
mí me encantaría invertir con ellos con
la corporación
a prestarle mi no sé millón de dólares a
mí mi billón de dólares sin embargo no
puedo hacerlo aunque ellos están
dispuestos a pagarme el 8 por ciento de
intereses pero yo no puedo invertir con
ellos porque yo solo puedo invertir con
compañías calificadas de deja para
arriba así que yo como fondo de
pensiones a mí no se me permite
prestarle dinero a la corporación a
entonces qué hago
qué hago qué qué hago a no sé qué hacer
porque la calificación de crédito
corporativo que le dio moody no es lo
suficientemente alta y bueno aquí
justamente aquí es donde entre las
permutas de incumplimiento crediticio
ahora imaginemos un
ideal un mundo maravilloso ideal para la
corporación a donde yo le presto ese
billón de dólares a la corporación a un
billón de dólares y ellos ellos en
retorno me dan me dan por cada año un
porcentaje de interés de antes dije 8
pero vamos a decir 10 por ciento de
interés por año entonces digamos dentro
de 10 años yo ya tengo mi billón de
regreso y estoy feliz y contenta
celebrando ahora no puedo hacer esto lo
he dicho múltiples veces porque la
corporación al tiene una calificación w
y recordemos que yo solamente puedo
hacer negocios con compañías con
calificación de hacia arriba a doble a
triple a por supuesto así que yo voy con
esta otra compañía aeg american
international group líder mundial en
servicios financieros y seguros yo voy
con ellos ellos se dedican a permutas de
incumplimiento crediticio de hecho hay
varias varias compañías que hacen todo
esto también por ejemplo bancos y bueno
ya con todo esto dicho pensamos en la
siguiente pregunta que hace ahí que por
mí que puede hacer a dije por mí
es que todo moody's mood y califica a
ese entonces supongamos que le puse una
muy buena calificación analizo a hija y
le puso una doble a por qué porque leyó
toda su información hizo un buen
análisis que analizó todo eso y dijo
guau
gm sorprendida dije s excelencia de
hecho si tú le prestas ahige ahige hay
poco riesgo de que te falle entonces les
voy a calificar con doble a y aquí otra
cosa también moody quien le paga moody
para que califique también hay que ver
de qué manera califica moody's bueno es
algo no es relevante en este vídeo lo
veremos en otra ocasión y bueno
regresando al tema aquí hay que le dice
a la funda a la fundación al fondo de
pensión bueno yo sé que tú quieres
prestarle a la corporación y la
corporación adquiere que tú le prestes
pero hay un problema ellos tienen
calificación w así que qué te parece que
te parece fondo de pensiones si nosotros
te aseguramos esa fianza lo que hay que
quiere del fondo de pensiones es una
prima de seguros ahí que quiere que le
pague un porcentaje de ese 10%
de pensiones recibe cada año de la
corporación nada quiere que quiero un
porcentaje como interés entonces
supongamos de ese 10% que recibe el
fondo de pensiones el fondo de pensiones
le da
el 1 por ciento cada año a 1 por ciento
y de hecho este 1 por ciento aquí es en
nigeria financiera 100 puntos base sólo
para aprender un poquito de del lenguaje
usado en finanzas 100 puntos base de
hecho un punto base es lo mismo que un
centésimo de 1% así que tenemos un por
ciento es lo mismo que 100 puntos base 2
por ciento es lo mismo que 200 puntos
base y bueno de esta manera ahí que
quiere
100 puntos base del 10% que se le da al
fondo de pensiones cada año ahí que le
pide 100 puntos base y en cambio le va a
dar el seguro con respecto a la deuda de
la corporación a entonces seguro seguro
de la deuda en a ahora tal vez esto ni
siquiera fue estructurado de esa manera
tal vez la estructura fue que la
corporación antes de emitir los bonos
ellos ya incluyen esta aseguranza con
los bonos entonces
dan el 10 pero se quedan con el 1% para
asegurar todo y estos después se
convierten en calificados doble a en
bonos calificados doble a ahora te
preguntarás bueno porque a la
corporación así vemos es w pero están
siendo asegurados por alguien doble a
así que de repente estos bonos por ser
asegurados por una entidad doble a el
cual moody calificó de esa manera estos
bonos son ahora lo suficientemente
buenos para que el fondo de pensiones
los tenga aún si la corporación entra en
bancarrota tengo este tipo de
calificación doble a asegurando la y lo
convierte de repente en un bono doble y
cuál es mi tasa de interés activa
veamos yo estoy obteniendo un 10% al año
de la corporación y después tengo que
pagar el 1%
y si la corporación entra en bancarrota
a higiene va a dar mi millón de dólares
en retorno y dirás guau esto suena muy
bien pero aquí se pone un poco
sospechoso porque vamos a poner un poco
de atención aquí analicemos esto ahí que
no sólo están asegurando mi préstamo
que le di a la corporación y piensa en
esto ahí que no tuvo que mover un pelo
al respecto ellos no tuvieron que poner
ninguna garantía ahí que no dijo oye
sabes que de todos nuestros activos aquí
tenemos a este billón que vamos a dejar
a un lado sólo por si acaso la
corporación nada no llegara a pagar
ahora tú pensarías que si quieres tener
la garantía de que ese dinero va a
regresar a ti hay que tendría que
guardar ese dinero pero no ellos no
tuvieron que hacer eso ellos solamente
dijeron hey jude y aquí nos dio una
buena calificación nos dio una
calificación doble a así que tú
encárgate de pagarnos el 1% al año y
confía en nosotros confía en la
calificación que moody nos dio a ellos
no tuvieron que dejar el dinero a un
lado no tuvieron que guardarlo así que
estás en una en un acto de fe que si la
corporación a llegar a entrar en
bancarrota
ahige no quedará mal contigo ahora aquí
la situación se pone interesante
hay que no sólo tuvo que asegurar mi
deuda
digamos que existe otra corporación
llamémosle la corporación se la voy a
poner aquí está la corporación sé que
tiene una deuda y supongamos que esta
corporación tiene una calificación de
más
digamos que hay una deuda de esta
corporación de 10 billones que le
prestaron otra compañía y en cambio
ellos regresan 10 billones y ellos
regresan el 11 por ciento este de aquí
es el fondo de pensiones el que le
prestó llamemos del fondo de pensión
este fondo de pensión tenía el mismo
problema ellos sólo podían comprar bonos
con calificación aaa o superior así que
hay que también asegura la deuda que el
fondo de pensión b le dio a la
corporación se quizás la corporación se
implica un poco más de riesgo así que de
ese 11 por ciento debe entonces pagará a
ig lo que son 150 puntos base 1.5 por
ciento de lo mismo y en cambio ellos
aseguran la deuda de se aseguran las
deudas de cee ahora algo muy interesante
puede suceder aquí hay que tiene de
repente un excelente modelo de negocios
debido a su calificación doble a que le
dio moody ellos pueden seguir asegurando
las deudas de otros y ellos no tienen
que guardar dinero ellos simplemente
reciben estas entradas ellos siguen
recibiendo corrientes de ingresos desde
mi fondo de pensiones
ellos están obteniendo veamos aquí está
el 1 por ciento al año 1 por ciento al
año de mi fondo de pensiones y del fondo
de pensiones de ellos están obteniendo
150 puntos base que es lo mismo que 1.5
al año así que hay que puede hacer esto
francamente todo lo que quiera ellos
pueden hacer estos mil veces siempre y
cuando moody no se ponga sospechoso del
asunto mientras que moody no diga hey
espera un momento dije tú solamente
tienes 100 millones de activos pero
estás asegurando un trillón en deudas de
otras personas
hay algo sospechoso contigo voy a
bajarte esa calificación mientras esto
no suceda hay que seguir a gusto porque
mientras ninguna de estas deudas quede
mal en sus pagos ellos seguirán
recibiendo estas excelentes corrientes
de ingreso así que creo que ya ves aquí
en el punto de fallo
seguiré con esto en el siguiente vídeo